[Musique]
autre dossier fondamental la formation
et l'emploi comment des entreprises se
mettent au service de ceux qui sont
éloignés justement du monde du travail
[Musique]
on va ouvrir maintenant dossiers
essentiels caisses de l'entreprise des
associations et de l'insertion 6 gtdi
potiron team 10 4 broches pas je pense
ou
à la soupe je me disais
non en fait j'ai papa je te parlais
d'une association qui est et qualys qui
des jardins partagés dans lesquels on il
emploie des gens qui sont un peu exclus
de l'emploi et puis des boutiques dans
laquelle ils vendent ensuite qu'ils
écoutent et danser dans ses jardins et
ses boutiques ça s'appelle les potirons
les potes iront rouler pire on peut la
clé ça comme on veut et on est allé on
est allé les voir quelques élus leur
travail c'est un reportage de céline
charles
[Musique]
les potirons c'est justement
proposer des légumes qu'on produit à
travers des jardins de cocagne que nous
avons et qu'on met en vente avec des
boutiques avec un camion et aussi des
sensibilisations et de la formation sur
la permaculture en milieu urbain comme
ici
on fait des plantations en fait c'est
pour montrer aux gens qu'on peut planter
sur des petites parcelles qu'on peut
faire des choses même si on n'a pas des
ha mais sur des petites parcelles et ben
on fait des plantations de fleurs de
légumes notamment des courges
[Musique]
alors c'est pas forcément pourra faire
des futurs jardiniers ou des techniciens
en espaces verts pour les collectivités
mais c'est surtout un support qui leur
permet de se redynamiser de sortir de
leur quotidien et d'être accompagnés
vers un véritable projet professionnel
l'idée c'est vraiment de leur redonner d
un cadre au niveau du professionnel
savoir arriver à l'heure le savoir-être
être présents ne pas être absents
écouter des consignes comme dans
n'importe quelle entreprise
mais professionnellement ça m'apporte
beaucoup non seulement le savoir être et
le savoir faire que j'avais déjà et j'y
suis depuis quatre mois maintenant et ça
se passe super bien j'apprends plein
plein de choses et voilà je suis dans
une équipe avec des gens formidables
il encadre aussi et puis le suivi aussi
les tops
les adore les adore et j'adore aussi
leur travail avec nous parce que c'est
vraiment un échange chacun
son sens son savoir donc tous les
savoirs son partage on a vraiment cet
esprit d'équipé tous les matins je suis
heureux de venir au travail parce que je
sais que deux je vais apprendre bien
plus que je leur apprends franchement je
suis bien de voir
comme à l'habitude c'est magnifique
[Musique]
alors ici vous êtes dans la boutique les
potirons une boutique qui a été créé il
ya trois ans ça fera trois ans à noël
qu'on ait ouvert ici il ya plusieurs
objectifs c'était de répondre à un
besoin de commerces de proximité offrir
voilà aux habitants des produits locaux
et des fruits et légumes bio 2 c'était
de créer de l'emploi et permettre à des
personnes éloignées de l'emploi donc
sans emploi de retrouver du travail et
de venir travailler dans ce dispositif
qu'est la boutique et 3 c'était de le
troisième objectif c'était de travailler
avec les agriculteurs locaux et de
valoriser la production locale
[Musique]
j'étais recherché d'emploi et me
concerne j'ai récemment parlé 17 de
cette association du coup bah voila j'ai
fait en sorte de postuler ici ça me
permettait d'intégrer doucement le monde
du travail parce que c'est pas très
simple par exemple de commencer avec un
mi temps
ensuite sur 35 heures donc petit à petit
mais sérieusement augmenté aujourd'hui à
35 oui
[Musique]
ce sont des personnes qui sont à la base
à la recherche d'un emploi donc sans
emploi qui ont besoin de retrouver un le
chemin vers l'emploi durable et donc
nous on est un tremplin pour eux pour
les aider à retrouver un emploi plus
perrin derrière
[Musique]
depuis le début je dire ça m'a apporté
de la confiance ça c'est important ça
permet de renouer avec le monde du
travail aussi le regard des autres
droite on peut pas se cacher derrière
et voilà surtout ça la confiance et du
dynamisme parce que quand on est
longtemps arrêté
ça remet la machine en route on
s'habitue à nouveau aux heures
[Musique]
je sais que la première chose qu'on va
regarder c'est sur mon cv c'est si j'ai
de l'expérience dans ce domaine et là
c'est le cas j'apprends et
j'apprends petit à petit et jacquire des
compétences et surtout c'est très
enrichissant pour les produits et donc
ses légumes bio sont valorisés en
circuit court dans notre boutique et on
retrouve tous les légumes de saison et
bio toute l'année on a beaucoup de
produits du 78 pour tout ce qui est
produits carnés produits laitiers et
fromages aussi des produits d'épicerie
pour ainsi de la truite fumée du 78
pourquoi on s'est vraiment travailler en
local
[Musique]
c'est bien c'est formidable c'est ce
qu'ils font c'est extraordinaire ça
permet justement de remettre le pied
dans le couloir dans le voilà exactement
et c'est ce que vous aussi de deux
invités vernis viger bernie virginie
visé bonjour bonjour vous êtes le tetris
général de sténo formations hostiles aux
formations c'est une association
de formation comme son nom l'indiqué
dans les métiers de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration
alors vous faites de la formation et
vous faites aussi de l'insertion ça
absolument alors en fait on fait de
l'insertion par la formation à
l'information tout à fait et
jean-françois lutins bonjour vous êtes
le directeur général de val de seine
alors val de seine se sont d'aider des
entreprises qui collectent et qui crient
et qui trie des textiles c'est ça oui
non
excusez moi bonjour je suis jean
françois lucquin donc
oui je représente le relais val de seine
donc on collecte et en tri des vêtements
et c'est une structure d'insertion aussi
chantent ouvèze qui emploie 150
personnes dont la moitié en insertion
dont la moitié en natation étaient tous
les deux vont voir parler de jacob de
vos associations et de votre entreprise
vous adresser aussi à des gens qui sont
assez éloignées de du domaine de
l'emploi très éloignées même
raisonnement tout à fait à la fois des
gens qui sont déjà en emploi mais aussi
des gens qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi alors on va commencer par val
de seine s'ils voulaient bien c'est une
entreprise qui a été créée il ya ya
quelques années quand même sous
l'impulsion
de la fondation de l'abbé pierre fin de
2006 mais
l'entreprise et a été créée en 1994
c'est un l'issue d'un reportage séné
dans le nord de la france d'une
communauté emmaüs donc d'une communauté
emmaüs les gens sont c'est l'accueil
inconditionnel un papier sans papiers on
accueille des gens qui sont éloignés de
l'emploi pas qu'ils sont à la rue plus
tôt et puis vivre dans un système
associatif vous leur donnez ce que vous
voulez ils revendent les gens sont logés
nourris blanchis au sein de cette
communauté dans les années 80 il y avait
de plus en plus de jeunes de 20 25 ans
qui arrivait et la communauté de
l'époque s'est dit c'est quand même pas
possible de garder des jeunes de 20 25
ans toute leur vie logé nourri blanchi à
vivre de cette façon là donc ils se sont
dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire mais il
faut l'arrivée à leur redonner un
salaire comme on fait pour donner un
salaire mais il faut créer des richesses
comment on fait pour créer des richesses
boeuf offert des entreprises donc on a
fait des entreprises par accident avec
l'unique but non pas de rémunérer un
capital mais de permettre à des gens
éloignés de l'emploi de retrouver le
chemin du travail c'est comme ça qu'on
est né il ya un petit reportage
télévisuel et puis pierre cardo un soir
devait s'ennuyer l'été devant sa télé il
a vu le truc ici dit tiens il ya 35 % de
chômage il embauche des gens éloignés de
l'emploi moi je sais pas quoi faire il
est en train d'essayer de développer la
zone industrielle à l'époque mais le
souci c'est que les entreprises elles
recrutent et assez peu de chantelouve et
donc il s'est dit ben on va aller les
voir est-ce qu'ils sont d'accord et puis
c'est comme ça qu'on est arrivé là mais
parce qu'avant ça parce qu'avant ça vous
aviez déjà dirigé d'autres structures
vous je crois alors moi je travaillais
déjà dans d'autres endroits ailleurs en
france et sur chantelauze chanteloup
jute la savoie la suite à sa cp de suite
à ça sur chanteloup on a créé une autre
structure qui s'appelle espérance qui
fait de l'insertion aussi par l'activité
économique
donc à chaque fois les les entreprises
qui sont décodés coopérative elles elles
ont pour but unique de remettre des gens
éloignés de l'emploi au travail les leur
redonner désorientés peut-être vert
réalisme s'ils ont envie de faire une
formation qualifiante dans les métiers
de l'hôtellerie ou de la restauration ou
que sais-je nous notre objectif c'est de
le redonner de l'employabilité de léran
briller sur leur pas courte sur le rêve
de leur vie quelque part de leur faire
aimer émerger ça et puis de les renvoyer
donc différentes structures il ya le
relais où on collecte on trie on revend
du textile des ménages vous pouvez nous
donner si voilà les événements je repars
avec tout de suite là pas de problème
donc une meilleure qualité si possible
même dans la salle ainsi
on a la tête ratée
donc voilà et
sinon êtes vendeur
sur espérances on fait du
conditionnement à façon donc ça veut
dire par exemple les shampoings les gels
douche vous les vendez vous pouvez les
acheter par deux avec une gaine
plastique on va aller monter et on va
aller on va les préparer pour les
envoyer dans la grande distribution fait
aussi pas mal de préparation de vente
e-commerce est sûre chanteloup il ya
aussi une association qui s'appelle défi
services plus ou là on va former des
gens éloignés de l'emploi aux métiers du
service à la personne ils sont des
métiers qui en ce moment sont très
demandés on cherche énormément de pertes
de ce don conforme à peu près il ya en
permanence il ya 150 personnes vraiment
qu'ils sont formés qu'on envoie chez les
particuliers dans les entreprises alors
vous a rendu visite à chaud tout dans
cette opération de tri de réutilisation
des textiles je propose de regarder un
reportage de justin brasier vous avez
sans doute déjà vu ces bornes dans votre
ville peut-être même les avez vous déjà
utilisé pour donner des habits des sacs
des chaussures mais savez vous comment
les vêtements sont ensuite triés et
réutilisées par la suite par tous
ensemble à la découverte des coulisses
du relais val-de-seine de chanteloup les
vignes
[Musique]
chaque matin les chauffeurs du relais
parts à 6h30 et sillonne les yvelines
pour récolter les sacs de vêtements dans
les bornes les rôles zain vers 13 heures
14 heures pour décharger les vêtements
les chaussures qu'ils ont collecté après
avoir été déchargés les vêtements sont
disposés sur un tapis roulant pour être
triées entre différentes catégories donc
là sur le tapis les deux premiers postes
de tristes des postes sont réservés à la
qualité boutique verte lieu fait valoir
pour mission de prélever des vêtements
que l'on va ensuite revendre en eau
propre prix prix on a 8 mars comment
donc deux à paris et puis le reste dans
les yvelines une dans le val d'oise qui
attend 3 pour trouver une nouvelle vie à
chaque vêtement il existe une
cinquantaine de catégories différentes
de chaque branche et c'est une catégorie
durfy casse dans l'est particulièrement
fier de remettre ce sont des vieux jeans
qui vont être envoyés dans le nord de la
france dans une usine du réseau relais
pour fabriquer angels appelle le métis
ça permet de donner aux vêtements une
seconde vie qui est assez longuement sa
pénurie 15 20 ans qui sert en isolant
écologique puisqu'il est fait à partir
de
d'une matière première
vous pouvez plus être utilisé en tant
vêtements
donc on a le sel et le bn c'est ce qu'on
appelle la coupe chiffon lacouchie fond
couleur la confiture blanc donc ses
vêtements ils vont être découpées en
chiffons d'essuyage
destination de l'industrie automobile et
à la fin de la chaîne de tri les
vêtements arrivent sur l'île aux
boutiques où une dizaine de personnes
tri de nouveau les habits en fonction
des saisons pour ensuite les revendre à
petit prix dans l'es8 triperie du relais
val de seine sur l'ensemble de vêtements
et chaussures qu'on collecte y en a 5 à
6 % si on part fait état pour à pouvoir
revendre dans nos tripes donc ça fait un
vêtement sur 20 qui va être vendu en
france est elle de 3 14 ans
la rode à becqueter sélection alors je
dis toujours c'est carton que je préfère
parce que forcément c'est avec tout et
ma
vie mais qui revient techer
ya des eaux il ya la femme alors la
flamme qu'on appelle la femme d'enlever
tous les hommes et on a que le bât
pantalons jupes et quelques ça permet à
bt et lorna on a le carton hommes à
l'envoyer on en a qu'un seul carton
parce que les amis dépense pas beaucoup
dans leurs vêtements le centre de
collecte propose également certains
vêtements à des créateurs de mode ou des
grossistes ils sont environ une dizaine
à venir s'approvisionner directement sur
le site les jeunes créateurs qui
souhaitent proposer des défis n'est que
avec des vêtements de seconde main qui
vont retravailler donc ça aussi c'est ça
fait notre fierté outre la collecte et
le tri des vêtements le rené val de
seine est avant tout une entreprise à
but socio-économique
c'est à dire qu'elle ne recherche pas la
performance économique pour le profit
mais pour atteindre des objectifs
sociaux chaque centime généré est
réinvesti à des formes de lutte contre
l'exclusion de relais val de seine c'est
une coopérative du mouvement emmaüs donc
elle collecte elle crie elle revalorise
des vêtements et cette activité que dans
lequel sert de support à une mission
sociale on est une entreprise
d'insertion retenir qu'on accueille des
personnes pour des contrats qui dure
deux ans maximum pendant lesquelles ils
sont accompagnés formé vers un retour à
l'emploi pérenne aujourd'hui il ya plus
de la moitié des emplois qui sont des
emplois donc pour l'insertion ça veut
dire que ça permet des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
de se re professionnaliser
professionnaliser tout court est de
retrouver de l'emploi par la suite donc
certains restent aussi initié et la
plupart vont retrouver dans l'emploi à
l'extérieur donc ça c'est une grande
grande joie et c'est le but notre
activité parmi les 140 personnes qui
travaillent au relais val-de-seine 90
sont en insertion vous avez là
depuis 2004 des plus grands tueurs
herlin après les passants occupent et
enfin sucre accuse alors le métier
trackers s'éteint c'est quand les
chauffeurs et ramène les sacs classiques
des vêtements je dois le crack est ok en
triant de maisons pour les blousons les
chaussures et les jouets d'enfants et le
reste servant sur le tapis ces défis qui
trie ses traits physiques c'est ben
c'est pour ça que je fais la première
femme
à le faire ici parce que ben hilli a
repoussé les bas qui sont très lourds
après il ya des garçons qui m'aident
aussi parce que ont lâché une fille
après monchy une personne qui est assez
dynamique donc c'est ça que j'aime
lorsque de buzz était sur le tapis donc
c'est moi qui ai un peu poussé pour
revenir ici et en plus de ça on a un
tonnage affaires de 4 nuits sens par
jour bon bah c'est physique mais c'est
bien l'année dernière le relais
val-de-seine de chanteloup-les-vignes
récolté 6200 tonnes de vêtements ce qui
équivaut à environ 20 tonnes de
vêtements par jour on sait
qu'aujourd'hui une grande partie du
vêtement c'est de la fast fashion
donc cédé souvent des vêtements de basse
qualité en france chaque année 80 % des
vêtements finissent leur vie aux ordures
ménagères le relais val-de-seine de
chanteloup les vignes a pour objectif en
2023 de s'agrandir et de trier 8000
tonnes de vêtements par un on
n'encourage pas la sueur à la
surproduction on préférait que les
quantités baisse que la qualité des
vêtements s'améliore que
les personnes prennent encore plus en
leurs vêtements
plus tôt fait de connecter toujours plus
faiblement en plus de la collecte du
réemploi du recyclage de vêtements et du
développement de boutiques le relais val
de seine vient également de créer sa
propre marque l'objectif recréer des
vêtements qui ne peuvent plus être
portée ont lâché de lancer notre propre
marque de cinq lignes leur en décembre
avec 150 pièces pour un premier test le
concile de luther king c'est de prendre
des vêtements comment elle pas pu
reloger en tant que vêtements on
conseille par exemple une belle chemise
mais dont le bail troué et on va
retravailler des pièces ensemble pour
vos fabrique un vêtement baptisé air up
cycling et la marque propose des pièces
autour des 30 à 60 euros
là vous avez par exemple de suite qu'on
a
[Musique]
cousu ont ensemble pour en faire à
nouveau à partir de deux sweet qui était
complet plus reporté en l'état est en
fait un nouveau vêtement pendant en
donnant vos vêtements vos chaussures
votre linge de maison ou encore de la
petite maroquinerie vous faites ainsi un
geste écologique mais aussi solidaire en
trente ans le relais à créer plus de
2200 emplois et intervient sur
l'ensemble du territoire français
pionnier de l'économie circulaire et de
l'insertion il démontre que
professionnalisme et solidarité sont
compatibles voila voila c'est donc ce
que vous faites à chanteloup même
jean-françois du temps
ça veut dire un jour moi je voulais je
voulais travailler être au service du
plus grand nombre et pas celui des
actionnaires
un ça à peu c'est un peu ça votre votre
profession de foi si je peux dire en
fait ma profession de foi si j'avais
envie de me sentir utile et disons que
je me sens plus utile à faire ce que je
fais aujourd'hui que faire autre chose
après chacun trouve son utilité là où il
a envie pas de jugement particulier mais
moi j'avais envie de me sentir utile
pour la collectivité c'est là je les
trouvais et vous avez des chiffres alors
sur chouïa combien à peu près de deux
personnes qui sont employées par val de
seine elle remise dans l'emploi donc sur
le relais val de seine on et 150 à
chanteloup et on a eu notre entreprise à
bordeaux où il ya 110 salariés il ya
donc ça c'est sur l'activité de
recyclage textile sur le conditionnement
il ya 50 à 60 personnes en permanence et
à défi services y à peu près 150 fiches
de paye par mois donc ça doit faire si
on additionne
150,50 350 dont 60% sont déjà en
insertion qui entrent et qui sortent de
façon permanente et un moment où vous
dites justement que ce que vous faites
est très important parce que vous faites
de la formation de l'insertion mais
parce que ce que vous faites et bien
je sais pas si c'est bien disons que
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire et
c'est ce qu'on fait avec les équipes je
fais pas ça tout seul on est toute une
équipe nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est
de tendre la main à quelqu'un qui veut
s'en sortir et dans la mesure où la
personne elle a envie de faire quelque
chose juste elle nous tend la main nous
on veut dire ok viens on va te faire
monter puis après tu seras autonome donc
voilà l'idée c'est de faire grandir les
gens et de les rendre autonomes parce
qu'ils ont eu un parcours de vie avec
une cassure avec une difficulté
quelconque donc quelqu'un qui veut se
relever dans l'aide à se relever puis
après il est reparti donc c'est ça qu'on
a envie de faire cette séquence opel
insertion emploi du travail pour tout le
monde il peut y avoir du travail pour
tout le monde et aider y'a pas des gens
qui sont exclus du travail on peut
arriver allait aller les récupérer si je
peux aux prises ce bouquet pas très
jolies
verrines alors oui moi je pense qu'on
peut tout à fait heureux enfin récupérer
j'aime pas ce pauvre mais pas bien
les entraîner leur donner du travail
tout à fait c'est ce qu'on fait nous
puisqu'on fait pas du tout de tri par
exemple à l'entrée en formation on prend
tout le monde et ont créé des parcours
qui vont dépendre de la situation ils
sont en entrant pour qu'ils aillent à
l'emploi et les ce qui passe par votre
association ou votre entreprise
parfois ils sont riches ne reste pas
forcément c'est vous il trouve
facilement l'emploi ce qui est important
c'est quoi se donner un cadre aussi un
cadre de voile à respecter des horaires
respectés
ddd des choses à faire enfin des
désordres si on en reçoit le travail en
solo si c'est ça chez nous c'est
apprendre à apprendre ou réapprendre les
codes d'une entreprise donc avec tous
les codes d'une entreprise que vous
pouvez imaginer
et essaie de les replacer nous on arrive
là c'est un peu compliqué avec le co
vide mais aura neko vide on replace 80%
des gens qui viennent chez nous soit
dans les entreprises locales qui sont
très demandeuses de main d'oeuvre et qui
ont du mal à en trouver soit sur des
parcours de formation qualifiante parce
que les gens s'y rêver ce que disent
tout à leur fin si la personne rêve de
devenir boulanger mais qui là qu'il faut
absolument un ca pays bas on va trouver
la structure qui va le former aussi
carré pour
moi et voilà il ya un suivi des gens
après moi ce que je voudrais attirer
l'attention c'est que on a trop souvent
le lait l'habitude de regarder les gens
par leur problème c'est à dire que les
gens d'insertion ils sont bourrés de
qualité
ici sur chanteloup ya 60 ou 70
nationalités ou ethnies on en a 25 dans
les entreprises j'imagine que c'est
pareil avec wallis lire mon tort c'est
bon on dort internationl oui estelle
hoffhart va sur mes parts dont certaines
informations il se serait sans doute
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on
dort sur un tas de pépites est juste il
faut prendre le temps d'aller les
chercher de les révéler et les gens
après ils sont repartis nous on fait
juste ça coince et tout mais alors on
est à une période où on est qu'il ya
quand même pas mal de métiers qui sont
qui sont en tension
est-ce que vos formations vous les
adaptez à la demande du marché ou alors
vous former les gens en fonction de
leurs envies tout simplement nous on les
forme en fonction de leurs envies c'est
à dire que l'on part du principe que si
vous avez envie d'être joaillier on va
pas vous demander d'être faire du btp
par contre ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va faire découvrir des métiers à nos
salariés c'est à dire qu'on va organiser
des rencontres avec des entreprises en
interne de l'entreprise c'est à dire ce
qu'on va chercher à détecter ces les
capacités et les habilités que les gens
ont de façon innée ou ont développé dans
nos structures et dans quel type de
métier ils peuvent aller les exercer et
donc il ya peut-être des métiers
auxquels il pensait pas du tout et donc
si on voit des gens qui sont minutieux
qui sont précis ben on va aller chercher
des métiers en tension avec pôle emploi
on va dire dans ce domaine là il ya des
tensions donc qu'est ce qu'une
entreprise recrute donc on va venir
demander à l'entreprise de venir se
présenter elle va être bien contente
souvent parce qu'elle a du mal à trouver
et puis peut-être pis on va envoyer les
gens une semaine dans l'entreprise ils
vont découvrir ils vont voir comment ça
se passe et si ça leur plaît et on va
monter sur un parcours qualifiant avec
l'entreprise ou avec pôle emploi de
façon à ce qu'ils aient un emploi
derrière est ce que vous dites aussi et
ça c'est très très important de le
souligner par contre vous avez vous
beaucoup de deux grandes entreprises qui
sont vos clients pour pour les intruses
de paquetages en fin de note le
conditionnement missionnement et et vous
dites mais il se met il s'adresse pas à
tous parce qu'on fait de l'insertion et
ses vassaux nous parce qu'on fait du bon
du beau boulot c'est ça c'est important
de le dire ici viennent nous chercher
nos clientes conditionnement à façon ou
les particuliers chez lesquels on va
envoyer des gens pour faire du ménage si
vous on vous envoie une femme de ménage
j'ai pas envie que le ménage soit fait à
moitié c'est vrai que ce soit bien fait
donc nous on va apprendre cette exigence
anneaux à nos salariés aux personnes en
insertion parce que de toute façon ce
serait pas entre guillemets ça ainsi nos
clients il venait par charité chrétienne
ou charité je sais pas laquelle donc
l'objectif c'est d'offrir une même
prestation de service qu'à n'importe que
n'importe quelle entreprise mais avec
des gens en insertion c'est ça le
challenge
c'est quoi la différence du fait de la
formation et de l'insertion c'est quoi
la différence à la formation et
d'insertion justement alors nous on fait
surtout de la forme alors on fait de
l'insertion par la forme à la formation
puisque ont fait la différence entre
formation et d'insertion ces deux à
l'origine aux différents je pense que ça
cette insertion
comprend deux volets un premier volet
qui est vraiment la réadaptation ou
l'adaptation au monde du travail de
l'entreprise ou ou autre c'est pas
toujours des entreprises en soit ça peut
être du travail eux justement chez les
gens et c'est à domicile et puis la
partie véritablement formation qui est
acquisition de compétences pour occuper
un emploi justement donc ces deux choses
qui sont obligatoires voilà qui se
rejoignent obligatoire mort et
d'ailleurs on est allé voir ce qu'ils
commencent à se passer ici avant tout
pour stella formation pour la formation
donc de deux personnes dans le domaine
de l'hôtellerie la restauration
et c'est un reportage de mathilde froch
ou
créés par des restaurateurs stello
formation existe depuis 1967 ici à
chanteloup-les-vignes le centre s'est
implanté en 2018 un établissement pour
dispenser les formations en hôtellerie
et en restauration des formations à
destination de salariés mais aussi pour
l'insertion professionnelle avec une
douzaine de formation par an pour les
jeunes et les adultes on a beaucoup de
ces apps et qui par leurs difficultés ne
n'ont pas la possibilité de s'inscrire à
eragny une école hôtelière parce que
justement il y à cette lacune en
français qui fait qu'aucune école
va les prendre sauf que mme hanoune le
prend on leur apprend des métiers ils
ont une entreprise et on a un taux de
réussite de 80% à l'examen des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi qui souhaitent
intégrer la restauration collective dans
tu veux manger à la maison xi élever mes
enfants donc après ils sont tous rentrés
à l'école donc je voudrais reprendre un
travail donc je voulais pas un travail
trop compliqué par rapport aux horaires
par rapport à mes enfants donc la
fondation assez collective rentrer dans
mes dans mes critères moi je travaille
dans l'optique de permettre à ce public
d'obtenir des savoir faire des
compétences et pour pouvoir trouver
travail après ça ma satisfaction c'est
de savoir que j'ai des gens qui viennent
jeunes ou moins jeunes ont fait
apprentis on fait aussi des adultes
donc de différents horizons et leur
permette d'accéder à un diplôme voilà
donc d'obtenir les nouvelles compétences
et surtout derrière un travail ici les
apprentis se forment en conditions semi
réel l'établissement dispose d'un
restaurant d'application pouvant
accueillir 20 couverts il permet
d'intégrer les premiers gestes en
restauration ce jour là deux groupes en
pratique un groupe en cuisine et un
autre en salle ce restaurant permet aux
apprenants de faire les premiers gestes
en restauration de faire la mise en
place du restaurant il faut savoir que
ce restaurant est ouvert deux jours par
semaine à la clientèle extérieure donc
cette jeune personne justement elle est
en train de préparer l'eau chaude elle
va mettre un peu de vinaigre et elle va
policiers tout ce qui est vert et
couverts on a préparé les couverts parce
que vous venez nettoyer avant qu'est-ce
qui couverts assiettes et verres donc on
nettoie avant et ensuite on prépare la
mise en place nous allons
passer par la cuisine
donc ici nous avons ces messieurs qui
sont en train de faucher policiers les
assiettes et là nous rentrons dans la
cuisine là ici nous avons un groupe
aussi ce ne serait pas la production de
ce midi donc là le jeune homme est en
train de préparer des crèmes caramel
d'autres sont en train de préparer des
fonds d'état et là bas nous avons des
apprenants qui sont en train de préparer
les mégots pour service ce groupe par
exemple se forment en linguistique et
techniques culinaires en plus des savoir
faire en cuisine des cours de français
sont dispensés pour les aider à
s'insérer professionnellement principaux
critères pour candidater avoir des
notions d'anglais et surtout être motivé
c'est le cas de cet apprenti pour un nul
à l'enfance ase étrangers et aussi pour
faire la cuisine à pain la cuisine des
bases fausses et la restauration cuisine
première des choses est la motivation
nous avons pu rencontrer des personnes
ce matin s'ils sont en formation
linguistique et techniques culinaires
ces personnes ne parle pas correctement
france et n'écrivent pas correctement
français mais parce qu'ils sont motivés
par ce métier ils vont justement
acquérir plus facilement
les compétences pour pouvoir travailler
par la suite dans la restauration
collective pendant leur apprentissage
les groupes sont accompagnés par
différents formateurs au programme une
partie pratique pour acquérir les
techniques et une partie théorique pour
transmettre les connaissances de base
nécessaires au métier puisque les
produits parce que des fois il ya des
produits qui connaissent pas
qui ne connaissent pas dans leur pays
d'origine voilà après ça va être
beaucoup la technique
douleur et de farine
pourtant moi tu meurs moitié paris
[Musique]
mais là
on va passer
vous laisse le chercheur et en
pérennisant place faisait ça le matériel
foule aujourd'hui on crée une sauce
principalement avec des produits de la
mer voilà eux
c'est des choses qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire du coup
je leur apprend les bases
[Musique]
je
blick bien les choses pour comprendre
comment ça se passe ici on ne comprend
pas du coup une re re sic flics pour que
commence à se faire
en gros c'est quand même assez technique
donc c'est vrai qu' on est en guerre on
a une magazine beaucoup donc après ils
sont là aussi va premier rassurer si on
fait une petite erreur ou quoi que ce
soit pour nous dire si on fait bien ou
pas bien alors montre une fois après
c'est à eux de faire est bon pour que ça
rentre vraiment bien on est là qu loger
quand ça va pas de troupes qui s'en
sortent très bien c'est des gens qui
sont souvent un peu éloigné du parcours
scolaire traditionnel donc il faut
arriver à les motiver sur les cours
théoriques en faisant peut-être une
participation un peu plus active au sein
du court ce c'est pas leur truc alors
par contre ils s'épanouissent beaucoup
ses savoir faire et c'est l'objectif de
toute façon monsieur on les forme pour
des métiers pour l'heure le centre stylo
formation de chanteloup les vignes et
dispose d'une capacité d'accueil de 70 à
90 personnes des travaux devrait
s'opérer cette année pour doubler la
capacité d'accueil
et donc on l'a on a bien compris qu'il y
avait là formation il est aussi
l'insertion mais à quel public vous
adresser directement vous alors non on
s'adresse un peu à tous les publics
puisque on forme aussi bien des gens qui
sont déjà salariés qui travaillent dans
des entreprises et qui veulent grandir
dans cette entreprise mais aussi à des
gens qui sont demandeurs d'emploi vous
voir très très éloignées de l'emploi et
pas forcément au stade où ils demandent
un emploi mais plutôt au stade précédent
où il cherche quelque chose à faire et
puis et à se remettre dans une vie
peut-être plus normal par rapport aux
aux codes qu'on a nous notre vocation
c'est pas tellement fait de faire de
l'insertion même si finalement on y
arrive notre vocation c'est de ces
d'apporter aux entreprises d'hôtellerie
de restauration voire de tourisme mais
c'est vrai qu'ici c'est un peu moins
d'apporter la madoff dont ils ont besoin
du coup forcément eh bien on va chercher
tout le monde et il n'y a pas de frein
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas des gens qui
peuvent et des gens qui peuvent pas il
ya des gens qui ont envie et d'autres
qui n'ont pas envie en tout cas pas de
ces métiers là est ce que c'est vous qui
allez les chercher où se serait auto qui
viennent vous voir j'ai envie de dire
les deux alors on va les chercher
beaucoup quand même mais il y en a des
demandes spontanées mais on a beaucoup
de partenariat avec tous les acteurs
justement de l'emploi de l'insertion
et puis on fait de l'apprentissage donc
on a des jeunes aussi
co2 plutôt d'aider des femmes plutôt des
hommes vous se répartit à peu près au
céret party un parti non limitée de
cette épidémie thiémé de fable
jean-françois non nous paradoxalement on
a la chance d'avoir des métiers parce
que l'insertion par l'activité
économique se lancer des métiers pour
les hommes ouais et là on a la chance
sur les activités économiques qu'on
porte sur le conditionnement où la
collecte et le tri des vêtements ou la
revente des vêtements d'occasion ce 60 à
70% des emplois sont des emplois
féminins il est des choses qui sont
souvent assez rare en termes de services
et d'activité économique donc c'est
d'autant plus riches d'avoir ses
activités ici virginie visés parmi les
personnes qui sont passés par chez vous
il ya des parcours comme ça que vous
riez évoqué pour de raconter un peu ce
que deviennent les gens à huy est lié
d'être enfin il ya de très belles
réussites moi je dis que tout est une
réussite mais il ya des très belles
réussites on ad on a des des anciens qui
ont qui ont obtenu à la suite de
formation chez nous et de parcours donc
d'insertion qui ont obtenu des cdi dans
des très belles entreprises on a un un
serveur je crois au marriott
champs-elysées par exemple qui a obtenu
un cdi on était très clair
on a on en a un autre qui a un cdi au
train bleu donc au restaurant du train
bleu gare de lyon qui a encore une belle
maison comme on dit dans notre métier
dans les métiers de l'hôtellerie et de
la restauration
un cuisinier par exemple
à l'hôtel renaissance à la défense donc
oui on a des honda des belles réussites
dont on est très fiers vous les suivez
vous les suivez sur le long terme
alors on les suit oui on va évidemment
on prend des nouvelles et puis c'est
vrai que comme on existe depuis très
longtemps puisqu'on était si on est
installé que depuis 98 à chanteloup on
est une association qui existe depuis
1967 donc on a on voit revenir des aussi
les anciens qui viennent faire la
formation suivante voilà pour devenir
chef de cuisine pour devenir est-ce que
vous avez des idées autour de jean qui
justement qui eux sont passés par là et
qui reviennent chez vous pour pouvoir
former les autres oui absolument on en a
on en a on a beaucoup de formateurs qui
sont des anciens de chez nous qui ont
été les chéneaux
quelquefois en apprentissage mais
quelquefois en formation adulte
jean-françois du temps si vous osiez
val-de-seine sédouy alors chez nous
nous ce qui nous plaît ce qu'on cherche
à créer c'est qu'on replace les gens
l'expérience et faire en sorte que les
gens se
enfin après je veux dire c'est un peu
idyllique 1 il ya toujours des choses
difficiles mais ce qu'on aime bien c'est
les salariés qui reviennent
presque mandatés par leur patron en
disant vas voir au relais où va voir à
l'espérance wade fils il ya pas
quelqu'un parce qu'on a besoin de
recruter has been et ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on aime bien en
particulier on aime bien dans les
compagnies de bus local ou dans les
entreprises du coin ça on en aime bien
faire ça et après c'est pareil
l'encadrement chez nous les trois-quarts
de l'encadrement sont des gens qui
étaient en insertion qui sont restés par
philosophie parce qu'il voulait mettre
leur pierre à l'édifice de l'entreprise
et donc ils sont montés pour devenir
responsable et on les informe et on l'en
les accompagner au tour de st voilà
après il ya des cas aussi un peu rigolo
il ya une fille qui me citiez des
exemples une jeune femme qui est arrivé
chez nous de l'étranger sans rien et en
liant l'avait aidée à obtenir des
papiers pour le coot quelquefois ça
arrive qu'on fasse ça avec les
communautés maïs local l est de l a
vendu des vêtements en magasin elle est
partie sur un parcours de formation
qualifiante parce qu'elle voulait être
infirmière
et puis finalement on l'a perdue nous
après c'est fini le parti et puis dix
ans après là nous appliquons il ya trois
mois aujourd'hui elle est devenue cno
thérapeute et donc à la digue si vous
voulez je sais ce que l'hypnose peut
apporter pour la confiance en soi des
gens donc je vous propose de venir faire
des heures pour les salariés en
insertion pour dire merci de ce que
j'avais reçues donc ça c'est ont trouvé
ça super chouette quoi passer on y est
pour rien et ça revient tout seul quand
c'est
presque des cadeaux quoi oui c'est un
cadeau c'est quand je vivais ça veut
dire voilà bah c'est pour ça qu'on fait
ce truc là même si on n'avait rien
demandé quoi puissent bénéficier au
genre d'insertion sac est super et puis
il ya des il ya des emplois dans
l'hôtellerie la restauration et
évidemment c'est un même s'est même dit
le secteur on n'arrive pas à fournir les
besoins à la demande base alors cela
pour le coup c'est vrai que la crise
sanitaire a fait du mal et que le
secteur a perdu beaucoup beaucoup de
d'employés qui font des gros efforts
maintenant pour pour en gagner de
nouveaux mais oui alors là pour le coup
on est sur des on est sur des secteurs
où il ya de l'emploi enfin on peut
vraiment y aller
on a beaucoup de demandes est sûr de
trouver du temps on est sûr de trouver
des films dont nous reçoit beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes de vador offre
d'emploi d'entreprises un mot il ya
beaucoup de gens qui viennent de
l'étranger
ya parfois des problèmes de langues une
barrière de la langue ah ben oui il ya
souvent une barrière de la langue
et on forme à chanteloup par exemple sur
un parcours qui est extrêmement
intéressant qui est linguistique et
techniques professionnelles alors à
chanteloup ce qu'on fait c'est sur les
techniques professionnelles c'est des
techniques culinaires ils ont sur la
moitié du temps de la linguistique donc
du français et sur l'autre moitié du
temps des techniques les premières
techniques qui vont leur permettre
d'être utile et opérationnels
directement dans une cuisine
parcours qui leur permet essentiel
absolument c'est vital pour pour
travailler il faut qu'on parle la langue
de son patron jean françois parent c'est
une vraie difficulté d'un défi servir
plus là on va démarrer au mois d'avril
des séances de formation de français
parce que quand vous allez chez les
particuliers que le particulier laisse
des consignes sur un peu sur un carnet
vous me l'avez ça vous menez toyer sens
premier vingt faut être capable de lire
de comprendre de retranscrire un minimum
et dans les structures d'activités enfin
son relais aux espérances c'est pareil
quand nous on est très participative
dans le mode de fonctionnement donc en
fait c'est important que les gens
puissent comprendre apporté leur pierre
et on considère que quand on fait une
réunion il ya dix cerveaux c'est plus
malin que le seul cerveau du responsable
donc on essaye de mobiliser sa et du
coup le français c'est une vraie
difficulté est donc on donne des cours
de français et à côté pour les gens qui
souhaitent en prendre et c'est bien à
cette baptisé parce qu'on est voilà des
gens qui sort dans l'investissement pour
les autres c'est formidable bravo hein
c'est surtout merci de faire connaître
parce que c'est pas très connu qui est
qu'ils aient fait wind absolue grand moi
ce que vraiment c'est en leaders chose
c'est que
juste apprendre à regarder les gens et
l'autre parce qu'il sait faire et par
ses qualités pas par ces problèmes et je
pense que si on regardait les gens qui
arrivent là en ce moment il y en a
partout qui arrive mais il y en avait
déjà d'autres avant et on aura d'autres
demain si on les regarde juste parce
qu'ils s'affairent et plutôt parce que
plutôt que les regarder par le problème
qu'on nous mais on a zéro pourrait poser
je pense que sl faudrait la changer
c'est ce que disait pierre cardo
d'ailleurs il parlait de resituer l'être
humain ensemble du débat à chaque fois
et on est en plein dedans l'indien
planant
véritablement prendre en compte ce dont
ils ont envie et tout à l'heure mais le
métier dont ils ont envie ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire de leur vie et ça c'est
très important
merci merci beaucoup à tous les deux
[Musique]